and nancy you mentioned the community
they are continuing to mourn many have
found solace in service there among them
a chef with very close ties to buffalo
food
music and friendship the city of buffalo
on friday trying to return to normal
following last week's hate-fueled
shooting at a supermarket
there to help
chef darian bryan
his pop-up restaurant selling meals at
this public gathering the funds going to
help families of the victims
oh these folks are hurting so i'm like
you know what food is love and food is
won't bring people together
and i'm so like grateful that i could be
i put a smile on these folks face brian
originally from jamaica has become a
buffalo fixture we introduced you to him
on the dish back in 2021 you just don't
get the food and you get the entire
package the swag
he's been running pop-up restaurants a
catering business and worked as a
personal chef his clients include some
of buffalo's best known faces players on
the buffalo bills
the team joined brian this week as he
and an army of volunteers served
thousands of meals at the site of the
shooting for many that supermarket is
the only one they can easily access that
community is like where you can find
the most black people in buffalo that's
where they're all at and it's just one
grocery store for them so that's where
they all go and with that being closed
no there's no there's no produce for
them there's no healthy options
saturday's attack hit close to home for
brian he frequently shops at the store
and nearly brought his family there
around the time of the shooting i pretty
much know everybody who worked there my
kids go to daycare down the street from
about tops too so every morning when i
drop them off at daycare i just go to
tops to get the groceries for the day
he's hoping to continue helping his
neighbors and to find a more permanent
solution to feeding people in a
community he says is underserved i'm
like what can we do to help those folks
to get out
like you can't grow just stuck in one
area in one place
and for them to be worried about you
know
if they can go to the grocery store it
blows my mind there's only one grocery
store over there in the entire east
satellite
these folks got to travel miles to get
food now
because that tops is closed
that that doesn't make sense to me i'm
like yo something got to be done for
these folks
that tragedy showing another problem
there for this community i do want to
point out that darien sold a thousand
meals yesterday raised twenty thousand
dollars uh for the victims and their
families and next week he's going to
continue to give out meals at the store
to those who need them because that
community is in so much need good to see
every single member of the bills sabres
and the teams the city's lacrosse team
abandons show up
to serve and that continuing focus i
mean you've heard so much talk this week
about food deserts what happens when
there's no place to get good and fresh
food and that's the case now that this
tops is closed and that was a grocery
store the community had to fight for to
get in the first place food is love
though as he says